welcome back to our Channel I'm abar and
today we are delving into a crucial
aspect of web security that safeguards
our online experiences the web
application firewall or W in this video
we'll unravel the mysteries of what a
web application firewall is how it works
and why it's a vital Defender against
cyber threats whether you are a tech
enthusias or just curious about online
security you are in the right place so
let's dive in and just a quick info for
you if you want to upskill yourself
master cyber security skills and land
your dream job or grow in your career
then you must explore simply learn
cohort of various cyber Security
Programs simply learn offers various
certification and postgraduate programs
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like MIT it
kpur EC Council and many more
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready expertise in
skills like Advanced hacking Concepts
Network packet analysis ethical hacking
network security and over a dozen others
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in top TI product and security companies
and academicians from top universities
after completing these courses thousands
of Learners have transitioned into a
cyber security role as a fresher or move
on to higher paying job or profile if
you are passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pin comment
and description box you find a cyber
security program that fits your
experience and areas of Interest so
let's get started and here we'll start
with what is a web application Fireball
so web application firewall serves as a
protective barrier for websites and web
applications by monitoring filtering and
blocking HTTP traffic this crucial
security component operates in various
forms including network based poost
based or cloud-based configurations
typically deployed via reverse proxy the
WF is strategically positions in front
of one or more websites or applications
whether functioning as a network
Appliance server Plug-In or cloud
service the WF meticulously examines
each packet it employs a rule-based
approach to scrutinize layer 7 web
application logic identifying and
filtering out potentially harmful
traffic that could exploit
vulnerabilities Enterprises commonly
leverage web application firewalls as a
fundamental security measure their role
is vital in safeguarding web systems
against a spectrum of threats including
zero day exploits malware infections
impers and both known and unknown
vulnerabilities and one notable strength
of WF slic in their ability to conduct
customized inspections swiftly detecting
and preventing critical web application
security flows and businesses offering
products or services online such as
e-commerce platforms or online banking
services find wfs particularly
advantageous now we'll see how a WF
operates a web application firewall
operates through software an appliance
or a service serving as a critical layer
of defense for web applications it
meticulously scrutinizes HTTP request
employing a predefined set of rules to
distinguish between harmless and
malicious elements within the
communication the core elements of HTTP
conversation subjected to WF analysis
predominantly include get and post
requests get requests are employed for
data retrieval from the server while
post request facilitate the submission
of data to a server for altering it
State the WF in essence acts as a
gatekeeper intelligently Discerning and
filtering the content of these request
based on its tool set to ensure the
security and integrity of web
applications this Dynamic process allows
the WF to proactively identify and
mitigate potential threats such as SQL
injections and cross-side scripting
attacks contributing to a robust defense
against a myard of web application
vulnerabilities and now we'll move to
approach is used by wfs so WF employs
various approaches to analyze and filter
content within HTTP request and these
methodologies include white listing that
is number one and here WF adopts a
default deny stance permitting only
trusted request listed in a predefined
safe IP address registry wi listing is a
resource efficient compared to
blacklisting but may
inevident block legitimate traffic due
to its Broad filtering approach while it
offers efficiency Precision may be
compromised and then comes blacklisting
utilizing pret signatures blacklisting
blogs malicious web traffic and
safeguards website or application
vulnerabilities it employs a set of
rules to identify malicious packets
making it suitable for public websites
handling traffic from unfamiliar IP
addresses blacklisting is resource
intensive and requires detailed
information to filter packets based on
specific characteristics rather than
relying on trusted IP addresses and then
comes hybrid security a hybrid model
combines elements of both blacklisting
and white listing simultaneously aiming
for a balanced approach this model seeks
to leverage the strength of both methods
providing a more nuanced and adaptive
security strategy regardless of the
chosen security model WF scrutinize HTTP
infractions preemptively mitigating
malicious activity before reaching the
server for processing regular policy
updates are crucial for addressing
emerging vulnerabilities although some
wfs now incorporate machine learning for
automatic updates and then comes
importance of web application Fireballs
in modern expertise or modern
Enterprises in the ever expanding
digital landscape web application
Fireballs play a crucial role in
safeguarding Enterprises offering online
products and services whether it's
online banking social media platforms or
mobile applications businesses face a
constant threat of data leakage making
the implementation of a WF essential one
primary concern is the protection of
sensitive data like credit card
information and customer records often
stored in backend databases accessible
through web applications and cyber
attackers frequently Target these
applications to exploit vulnerabilities
and gain unauthorized access to valuable
data and for Industries like Banking and
compliance m standards such as the
payment card industry data security
standard PCI DSS is Paramount a WF
becomes a valuable asset in meeting
pcidss requirements specifically the
Mandate for a robust firewall system as
Enterprises increasingly adopt mobile
applications and engage in transactions
via the Internet of Things the
application layer becomes a prominent
arena for potential security breaches if
the WF emerges as a core cor Stone in
the modern business security model
however it's crucial to recognize that
the effectiveness of a WF is maximized
when integrated into comprehensive
security strategy this strategy should
Encompass other security components like
intrusion prevention systems intrusion
detection systems and both classic and
Next Generation firewalls the Synergy of
these elements ensures a robust defense
against evolving cyber threats in the
dynamic digital environment and now
coming to the types of web application
fireballs and exploring the options web
application Fireballs come in various
types each with distinct features and
considerations let's delve into the
three most common types number one is
network based wfs netork based wfs are
Hardware based Solutions installed
locally on premises through dedicated
appliances this proximity to the
application reduces latency enhancing
performance and major vendors facilitate
large scale deployment by allowing tool
and setting replication across multiple
appliances however the drawback lives in
the cast upfront capital expenditure and
ongoing operational expenses for
maintenance and then comes host based
wfs host based wfs integrate fully into
the application code offering a cost
effective solution with increased
customization options despite their
advantages managing host spased wfs can
be challenged Ching they rely on
application libraries and local server
resources demanding most of resources
including developers system analyst and
devops or Dev SEC Ops for Effective
management and then comes cloud-based or
Cloud hosted wfs Cloud hosted wfs
present a lowcost alternative ideal for
organization seeking a Tony product with
minimal management resources easy
deployment subscription based models and
simple DNS or proxy changes for
application traffic redirection
characterize these WF although
interesting a third party provider with
web application traffic filtering May
pose challenges it enables F spread
application protection across diverse
hosting locations and now we'll see the
WF examples number one is Barracuda then
Cloud Fair F5 and then more security
that is opsource web application
firewall then
nxi this is also open source and web
Knight that's also open source web
application firewor and there you have
it guys a closer look at the web
application firewall the unsung hero
protecting our web applications from
various threads if you found this video
informative don't forget to give it a
thumbs up share it with your fellow
digital explorers and subscribe for more
insightful content as always stay secure
in the vast digital landscape now
signing off and until next time keep
learning and stay ahead staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here